We define stress as the response to a
situation that a person perceives to be
overwhelming
in that the person does not think he or
she can meet the demands of the situation.
The interesting thing to note here, this
is the perceived
inability to meet the demand of the
situation facing them.
For example, perhaps you have a ten page
paper due in two days.
In addition, you have to work nights, and
you have a test the same
day the paper is due.
For some people, they may perceive this to
be
way too much for them to handle, and feel
that
they're unable to meet the demands of
getting the
paper done, studying for the test, and
going to work.
Thus, the person in this situation is
experiencing stress.
This is true for having projects due at
work or
also having to take care of household or
family responsibilities.